we're always able to lean into two
different energies which is a topic
we've spoken about often here on the
show but when people say oh I want to
get myself into a attracting power I
want to manifest more into my life they
often think that it's something that
they need to do like I need to make a
vision board or I need to talk about it
a lot or I need to affirm how I want to
feel I need to do do I need to meditate
more I need to read that book when
really the Simplicity is that it's not
so much about what we do but it's about
how we feel when we feel good we attract
more good into our life that is a core
through line of this show dear Gabby it
comes up over and over and over again
for me listen I try to find even the
most difficult circumstances as an
opportunity to lean into something
that's a better feeling vibration so
sometimes you may be thinking well how
could I lean into Joy when I'm dealing
with a diagnosis or when I have just
lost my job or when I am have living
struggles in my marriage or whatever the
problem might be this is when we really
have to get to work those moments when
things are difficult and there isn't joy
in sight that's when we have to do our
best to lean into the next best feeling
vibration Hey Kevin Carmichael and I
make these videos because in my first
business I was making 300 bucks a month
I quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was studying the
stories of super successful
entrepreneurs so I hope that this story
today helps give you the motivation you
need because I still needed to myself so
today let's live your best believe life
and learn the Amazing Power of Positive
Thinking enjoy
rule number two is overcome negativity
with Tom bilyeu my brain somehow finds
ways to trick me and keep me unmotivated
and negative all the time it's really
depressing to be like this and stuck in
a rut if you could help me overcome this
curse of negativity I truly appreciate
it and thanks a million for your efforts
all right
homie when I say I have the Silver
Bullet for this one this this is the
magic Genius answer that people were
looking for on the other one here it
goes
you do not need to think that you are
anything special it is absolutely okay
for you to be hopelessly average
why
to me the most powerful thing that you
could believe about yourself is that
you're the average human now why I
actually think it is less powerful for
you to think that you were above average
because to think that you were above
average means that you are valuing
yourself for being better than people
it's a super vulnerable position to be
in because you will inevitably meet
people who are better than you and what
do you do with your ego then then it's
really crushing you thought you were the
man and now you encounter somebody
that's better than you they slap you
around they outperform you they dunk on
you whatever and now whoa like you've
got to rebuild and Claw your way back
versus
saying the following
the average human is the ultimate
adaptation machine the as a species
humans have chosen to respond to
cultural and environmental cues so we do
not come pre-programmed like a horse
that comes out of the womb 10 minutes
later is ready to rock and roll it's
running around doing all the things that
a horse can do like human on the other
hand has this huge period of development
after birth where we cannot take care of
ourselves we can't walk can't hold our
own head up we've seen our pants it's
crazy
but what that does is it allows us to
drink in this the environment that we're
born into and adapt so the average human
is the ultimate adaptation machine
therefore being the average human means
you're a learner that's it you're not
exceptional so you're not putting any of
your psychology your
um self-worth your pride into being
better than somebody else
it all comes down to valuing yourself
for being the learner so hey cool you
wasted a bunch of time at school no
reason to hide from that it was a waste
we're not going to repeat the mistake
but we learn so you've got the
self-awareness to see that it was a
mistake now it's just like what do you
want to do what do you want to get great
at because if you apply yourself even if
you're not good yet
you can get good
how do I know that because you're the
average human and the average human is
the ultimate adaptation machine this is
all about discipline focused energy into
acquiring a skill set it's what I call
the only belief that matters when you
believe that time and energy directed at
something through deliberate practice
will actually make you better at that
thing
now all of a sudden it's like I can get
good at anything if I apply myself and
now all of a sudden your behaviors align
with your belief that's why that belief
matters so much because if you don't
think you can get better at something
then why would you apply any time and
energy to it and if you don't apply time
and energy to it then you really won't
get any better so it becomes this Loop
of well I believe I can get better
therefore I try therefore I actually get
better therefore I try harder and you
get in this virtuous cycle
this is hugely important that is one of
those things that will govern the rest
of your life you value yourself for
learning getting better at something and
applying yourself everything else will
take care of itself because you just
keep applying yourself don't make
excuses don't BS yourself if you wasted
time you wasted time don't spend your
time beating yourself up over it because
we only do and believe that which moves
us towards our goals right we talked
about that earlier so we're gonna do and
believe that which moves us towards our
goal and in this case that is the belief
that we can get good at anything now
there's an incredible quote I love this
quote so much
you can't make a racehorse out of a pig
but you can make a really fast Pig
your life can be the answer to what does
a fast pig look like that is certainly
what my life is all the success that
I've had in my life is not because I was
gifted at any one thing when I left for
college my mother quietly assumed I was
going to fail my best friend assumed I
was going to marshmallow my way through
life when I asked my father-in-law for
his Blessing to marry his daughter he
said no
and yet I went on to be successful to
earn my father-in-law's respect
um
not because they misidentified me
because they didn't they were right
but because I developed Drive I got the
only belief that mattered and I finally
realized that
humans are meant to grow and get better
at something and I just have to apply
myself and the same is true for you
decide what you want to get good at and
go after it with everything you've got
rule number three is fulfill your
emotional needs with Mel Robbins do you
know what your core emotional needs are
there are three of them
I want you to go in the comments what do
you think your three
core emotional needs are as a human
being these are the core emotional needs
that every human being needs in order to
feel safe
in order to feel connected to themselves
in order to feel loved what are those
core needs everybody I'd like you to
just write them in the comments okay yep
one safety one's love these are great
what else what are your needs your core
emotional needs I see longing I see love
these are excellent excellent responses
everybody human connection love
acceptance yep yep trust honesty what
are your core there they are I see
Felicia's nailed it to be seen
to be heard
and to be she says validated but it can
be validated accepted or celebrated for
the unique
individual that you are so to be seen
to be heard
and to be celebrated and accepted for
the unique individual that you are and
the unique contribution that you have
when you feel seen when you feel heard
and when you feel celebrated or accepted
for the contribution that you make as an
individual unique individual you feel
safe you feel like you belong
and at your core you feel loved when you
don't feel seen you feel invisible in
life
when you don't feel heard you're going
to feel misunderstood
and when you don't feel like you are
accepted or validated
you feel completely rejected and
disconnected
you feel like you are unworthy or
unloved and so again we're going to talk
about your need to be seen to be heard
and to be accepted and celebrated you
need this at work you need this at home
you need this in your relationships your
friendships your romantic relationships
your family and you know if you just
reflect in your life where do you feel
seen heard
and celebrated
where in your life do you feel that way
or is there a person in your life that
makes you feel that way
hopefully you are saying that you make
yourself feel seen heard and celebrated
but is there somebody else in your life
that makes you feel that way it could be
a caregiver it could be somebody that
you're in a romantic relationship with
it could be a mentor it could be a
friend it could be your pet right like I
mean I think one of the reasons why we
all love our cats and our dogs so much
is because there's such unconditional
love you walk in the door they come
running right at you and so you feel
seen and you feel celebrated right and
when they're right there with you or you
know have you ever noticed how when you
get really upset and you start crying
what do your animals do oh my God they
hear you and they come right on over and
I those responses that are so innate
when it comes to your pets everybody
their
fulfilling your emotional needs that's
why you feel so safe and connected and
loved by your pets because you feel seen
by them you feel heard by them and you
feel celebrated and loved by them and I
do see people saying I feel that way
about my daughter my mom a mentor of
mine these core values when they're
missing from your life of being seen
heard celebrated and accepted
this is what leads you to feeling stuck
in disconnected and unfulfilled and the
good news is when you realize that these
core fundamental needs truly dictate how
you feel and experience your life now
you've got the access point to be able
to change how you're experiencing your
life by focusing on your core
fundamental needs and making sure that
they are met all right
you need these three fundamental
emotional needs in order to thrive you
know they talk about this in Psychology
101 uh it's called Maslow's hierarchy of
needs and here's the background you have
basic needs that are fundamental to your
fulfillment your happiness and your
survival you know you need water food
oxygen shelter and sleep right because
if you don't have water or food or
oxygen or shelter or you get enough
sleep guess what you die that's how
fundamental these core needs are you
also know that you need friendship or
else you're going to feel lonely and
research shows that people die from
loneliness too it's a huge killer you
may also know that you have a
fundamental need to grow because if
you're not growing and learning as a
person you start to feel stuck in your
life
but what you may not know is that you do
have these core fundamental emotional
needs to be seen to be heard to be loved
for the unique individual that you are
and when these emotional needs are not
met it's not only a form of neglect
but you will feel unloved invisible and
unfulfilled and see I believe that's how
we all got so critical of ourselves in
the first place and it's why we're
twisting ourselves in knots ever since
that at some point in your childhood
those core fundamental needs stop being
fulfilled you started feeling invisible
you started feeling disconnected you
started feeling like you didn't belong
and as we talked about in yesterday's
video
this is all covered in chapter four of
the high five habit that you then turned
that that feeling against yourself and
you sort of go well there must be
something wrong with me there must be
something wrong with me no there's
nothing wrong with you it was that your
three fundamental emotional needs were
not being fulfilled by the adults around
you that's all that was wrong
so you can change this by the way for
yourself because what's missing if
you're not fulfilled in life is a deeper
connection to yourself because you've
probably been so busy running from one
thing to the next that you can't even
grasp right now how big of a shift it's
going to create when you start each
morning by simply seeing hearing and
honoring yourself and one of the reasons
why I love all the research around
adding a simple high five in the mirror
to your morning routine
is that it fulfills your deepest
emotional needs as a human being this
one action of just high-fiving yourself
in the mirror add it to your morning
routine how many of you have added a
high five to your morning routine and
you're stunned
by how much it's changing the way that
you see yourself the way that you treat
yourself
because as you've learned these three
emotional needs were probably never met
during your childhood and you haven't
been given the tools until right now
to be thinking about this and to start
fulfilling these emotional needs as an
adult
and you know the reason why you feel
invisible at work
or you feel outside of your friend group
or you feel disconnected in your
relationships as an adult not to mention
the relationship you have with yourself
is because there's something missing
and what's missing is a deeper sense
that you actually matter what's missing
is the sense that you are being seen and
heard and appreciated this is critical
it's so critical if you were to wake up
and you had a feeling of being connected
to yourself and you felt seen in your
life and you felt appreciated in your
life and you felt heard in your life
that would absolutely change how you go
through life also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is have a positive
attitude with Marie forleo if you ever
feel like you're missing out on some big
secret to success that everybody else
knows but you you are gonna want to
watch this one let me tell you all right
so a little story here a few years back
I was driving to a lunch meeting in LA
and there was a lot of traffic as usual
and not too much parking on the street
so I pulled into a garage with a valet
now what happened next was so unexpected
I opened the door to hand over my keys
and I got blasted by this guy
with unconditional love thank you
I gotta tell you this guy's energy was
so off the charts he was Latino probably
like late 60s and he was this total
Powerhouse of Joy the way he greeted me
was like he was picking up some lifelong
friend at the airport and he gently just
helped me out of my car he asked me
about my day and get this he was
genuinely interested in the answer and
then he flashed this smile at me that
was brighter than the California Sun I'm
not kidding this man was one of the most
enthusiastic Souls that I have ever met
in my life now one of the things that
struck me was that this was the valet
guy and as somebody who's worked in the
service industry for years I know that
these kind of jobs I mean they can be
challenging you're often dealing with a
lot of cranky people you're probably not
making that much money and honestly it
can feel thankless at times but this guy
oh my goodness the energy that he
brought to his work it was like he was
this happy King and he was welcoming you
into his Palace and the reason I wanted
to share this story is because it is
such a potent reminder of one of the
most underrated secrets to success there
is
it is not just about what you do it's
about how you do it you see Behavior
alone is not enough the energy the soul
the spirit that you infuse into your
actions it matters and I mean this
applies to your work it applies to your
relationships it applies to everything
you know as Jim Carrey said the effect
you have on others is the most valuable
currency there is and I mean you know
this to be true right there's such a
huge difference between someone who just
shows up and they kind of go through the
motions and maybe even worse they're
like a walking complaint I mean that
creates a completely different result
than somebody who shows up and like
they're full of warmth and enthusiasm
like they actually want to be there and
there are three reasons that I feel why
getting this is so so important number
one your attitude is contagious you know
we human beings we have mirror neurons
in our our brains that make our emotions
catchable meaning your joy Your
Enthusiasm all that stuff it rubs off on
people around you and so does a totally
crappy attitude kind of like germs
oh my God
somebody got joy all over me oh sorry
Marie that was me
you know what little Joy never hurt
anybody
so take responsibility for the energy
you're putting out there all right
number two this moment makes your future
moment so here's what this means how you
do what you do impacts how people
respond to you and very often the
results that you get so in the case of
my very sweet valet I was so grateful
for his energy that I gave him a very
big tip like probably three times the
standard amount and let's be honest
that's how all of us can build momentum
in this life by wowing other people and
doing that with your genuine heart and
your genuine caring and your attention
to detail and number three you can make
a difference in this world no matter
what you do for a living and really
really hear that you know I get so many
questions from people saying gosh I feel
like what I do just isn't that important
or Marie you know what I want to find a
way to make a bigger impact in the world
what should I do this is what you should
do don't just focus on what what you're
doing give attention to how you're doing
it because you have countless
opportunities every single day to change
real people's lives simply by choosing
to start infusing everything you do with
some genuine love and enthusiasm and
your humanity and just watch the
difference that it makes both for you
and for everybody around you rule number
five is get motivated with the Vanessa
van Edwards according to the research
the best motivator for helping people
achieve their goals is see progress in
his New York Times best-selling book
drive the surprising truth about what
motivates us Daniel pink pulls apart
four Decades of scientific research on
human motivation let's dive into what
the science says about how to motivate
yourself and others
small wins self-motivate we used to
think Financial incentives were the best
kind of motivation pink argues that this
is outdated the Deep human need to
direct our own lives progress is what we
should Champion over rewards whether
you're talking to your colleague your
spouse or trying to motivate yourself
highlight progress here's how when
sitting down to make your to-do list
every day start with what you've already
done yesterday up top write what you
have completed in the last 24 hours and
then what you want to complete in the
next 24 hours make a little ceremony of
checking off the progress you've already
made before doing more make scoreboards
for yourself and your team so you can
see how far you've come in the middle of
a big project this works for home
projects work projects and passion
projects when speaking with teammates
instead of saying what they have to do
next talk about what they did already
first when giving a compliment highlight
specific tasks they already achieved
don't talk about how much they have left
talk about how far they've come
self-motivating talk
what does it sound like in your head
sometimes I wish I could hop into
someone's head just to hear what they
are thinking our thoughts are secret and
it's a good thing too we're far more
brutal in our own minds and in reality
the problem is our thoughts matter here
are the major questions I have for you
when you talk to yourself are you nice
mean harsh sweet do your thoughts match
your actions would you be okay
broadcasting your thoughts the first
step to getting motivated is
understanding how your thoughts are tied
to your actions and if your self-talk is
holding you back
the brain believes what you tell it most
I recently picked up the book what to
say when you talk to yourself by Chad
helmstetter Dr helmstetter argues that
we are programmed by our thoughts
specifically he calls out something
called our self-truths self-truths are
the ideas we tell ourselves the beliefs
we carry around whether they are true or
not sometimes we learn self-truths from
Life Experiences other times we pick
them up from those around us we believe
what we are told by parents bosses and
teachers especially if the same idea has
been told to us over and over again for
example I believe I had no chance to be
good at math from a young age I was told
it wouldn't come naturally to me or that
math will be your worst subject and
sometimes even math is hard for girls
and guess what it was and is I wonder
what would have happened if I had been
told the opposite here's some other
common negative self-truths I hear
people say all the time I am horrible at
remembering faces I have terrible luck
I'm awful with people I'm not creative
things never work out for me I'm just
not the type of person who
do any of these sound familiar I want to
take a moment and have you think about
some of your self-truths what are some
limiting beliefs you say to yourself
fill in the blank I'm not good at
I always
I never
I'm just not the type of person who
I'm not very good at
if it was hard to fill these in or you
had positive thoughts amazing your
self-truths serve you if you had
negative thoughts pop into your brain
immediately then we have some work to do
these kinds of thoughts kill motivation
before you can even get started if
you're warming up your brain with these
kinds of thoughts there is no way you
can work or be productive as your best
self
motivation Buzz kills
the other kind of self-talk can come up
around certain people or in specific
situations I call these motivation Buzz
kills we have no chance of motivating
ourselves if we constantly are putting
ourselves down for example I feel very
out of place in nightclubs and Loud bars
my self-talk sounds something like I am
so uncool or I don't belong here this is
probably a learned self-truth I had a
few bad experiences early on and now I
just can't shake them a friend of mine
tends to chastise herself whenever she's
around her mother before driving over to
her parents house for dinner she'll sit
in the car and agonize I'm always so
late I never have my life together and
the sad thing is her mom says the same
exact thing the moment she walks in the
door honey you're always late you have
to be more organized you have to get
your life together this is a taught
self-truth that is turned into a
motivation buzz kill every time she goes
over to see her mom she is constantly
self-doubting which makes her more
disorganized and more late her mom
reaffirms the exact behavior and she
holds on to it where do you put yourself
down is it at work with your boss around
your parents with your friends with your
productivity at school with technology
with your health identify the areas
where you have the least motivation and
the most negative self-truths
limiting wishes
sometimes self-truths come in the form
of limiting wishes limiting wishes a
future state that we hope will solve all
of the problems from our current lacking
self for example one woman came into our
lab and told us that the reason she
can't make friends is because of her
horrible nose I look like a toucan she
said when I'm talking to people I know
all they're thinking about is my nose as
soon as I get it fixed it will be so
much easier to meet people let me ask
you a question have you ever not been
able to talk to someone because you
didn't like their nose no absolutely not
we tried explaining this to her in every
possible way we even had people watch
videos of her and rate her on a variety
of personality traits not one single
person mentioned her nose however she
was convinced of this limiting wish her
limiting wish was if only my nose was
smaller I would be able to make friends
here are some other common limiting
wishes if only I was thinner if only I
was taller if only I was richer if only
I was funnier if only I was smarter if
only I had got that promotion if only I
could move to that City if only I could
find a significant other if only I was
older if only I was younger do you have
any limiting wishes any desires that are
holding you hostage fill in the blank if
only I was
I wish I
everything would be better if I
limiting wishes make motivation
incredibly difficult because there are
barriers to productivity bottom line if
you think you need to change something
do something or have something before
you can get motivated then it will be
almost impossible for you to be
productive it's time to banish those
limiting wishes and get to action right
now
changing self-talk
Dr helmsetter says you can change your
self-talk first you have to admit you
have some negative self-truths we just
did that then you need to recognize the
need to change did you start this video
saying things like I need to or I should
great you are watching this video for a
reason so clearly you know you want more
motivation
hopefully this is where you are right
now the first half of this video was
getting you to think about changing some
of your negative cell truths and
limiting wishes now we have to decide
what change to make
change your internal voice
what is your internal voice sound like
for just a moment think about the voice
in your head you know the one that
comments on your actions or makes little
observations about the world around you
does that voice sound like the voice you
use in real life over the last few years
I have talked to people about their own
self-talk and more often than not I hear
them mention how mean the voice in their
head is and how that often they want to
talk to themselves in a much nicer way
than they do
would you speak to someone else the same
way you speak to yourself take a look at
this spectrum when you talk to yourself
where do you fall I'll be honest I am
extremely critical of myself when I
don't get something right I internally
berate myself if I mess up with
something or have a bad workout day I
internally chastise my laziness and lack
of willpower I actually had no idea I
was doing this until I began to write
down some of my internal thoughts action
step for you for the next seven days
carry around a journal or create a note
in your phone and write down every
single internal thought that goes
through your mind about yourself you
don't have to write down all of your
thoughts just the thoughts that are
assessment based when you judge yourself
both positively and negatively you want
to write down what you think about how
you do your tasks and activities
re-examine
examine the kinds of thoughts you have
on a daily basis see any patterns how
many positive thoughts did you have
versus negative ones I want you to take
out a sheet of paper and draw three
columns in the first one write down all
of your limiting belief patterns these
are your motivation Killers what
thoughts are counterproductive to you
being your best self or working at
optimal levels it might look like this
it seems silly but sometimes we've been
thinking something for so long that we
have forgotten what made us believe it
in the first place and we certainly no
longer challenge it I want you to go
through yourself truthless and write
down its opposite in a column called
opposite it should look like this this
is the hard part I want you to write
down all of the reasons why the opposite
is true sometimes this means finding
learning experiences from hard Memories
the goal here is to systematically
disassemble all of your self-truths that
are not serving You by looking for
evidence
your choice to self-motivate
now you have a choice you can live
automatically by default or you can live
purposefully with challenges and hard
truths I do not believe ignorance is
bliss I think truly living is embracing
truth about yourself the people around
you about how we work but only you can
decide to do this if you want to try
purposeful self-talk all you have to do
is complete the three steps above when
you begin to be self-critical I can't do
this all the time but it's what I try to
do most of the time this is how I've
overcome a lot of my social anxiety when
I find myself awkward in a social
setting I go through the same Three
Steps From Above for example a common
negative self-truth I say is I don't
belong the opposite is I belong evidence
I'm here to build my business I already
spoke to two new people I love learning
about people this is a great new
experience and so it goes it's a slow
process but it does help me challenge my
limiting beliefs it's not easy it
doesn't happen all the time but it's
exactly what it sounds like in my head
you have a choice to begin to slowly
change your self-talk and remove those
motivation Buzz kills
motivation mantra
we all need rituals routines and habits
to get ourselves motivated using the
framework above come up with a
motivation mantra for all of your common
limiting self-beliefs for example if you
tell yourself I'm so dumb the opposite
would be I'm talented the evidence is
that I have this great job I have done
this task before and my team is counting
on me you can do this tackle those
limiting self-truths one at a time I am
rooting for you rule number six is
eliminate self-doubt with Russell Brand
what are some ways to eliminate that
self-doubt and gain confidence
well self-doubt can be critical Lewis
because it can be a component of
awareness I feel that the answer must
always be the embarkation on a spiritual
life because
it's difficult isn't it in this world of
personal development that we find
ourselves in for us not to take on the
tropes and objectives of a culture that
I think at this point we need to be
querying querying and looking to move
away from we've all been deeply
inculcated to believe that the pursuit
of happiness is contingent upon the
attainment of our petty trivial desires
but real happiness is contingent on
being free from those Petty trivial
desires as long as I'm a prisoner to
that like you know see if someone's like
that that doesn't know you know then
come and pluck up the confidence to ask
someone out I can't pluck up the
confidence to pursue their dream or
whatever for me I don't feel like it's
my job to operate at that that
intersection at the intersection of well
come on believe in yourself you're as
good as anyone else you'll never know
unless you try you know I don't think
that's my job my job is like why do you
think you want this what do you think
it's going to do for you what do you
want really what do you really want what
do you really want what is it you are
looking for you know a friend of mine
observed once that in the 1980s The
prominent sort of entrepreneurs were all
about zipping about on speed boats and
whooshing through the skies in hot air
balloons Intrepid bold adventurers the
very same tycoons now are all about
green cynicology and safety and helping
responding to the trends that Define a
time this time now of apparent fragility
I think our job is to look for some
truth beneath culture that culture and
many cases is not our friend culture is
here to chain us to systems of tyranny
subtle tyranny what is freedom really if
it is only freedom to operate within
certain parameters it isn't Freedom at
all I'm not saying I wouldn't rather be
a person who is affluent in California
than a person that sort of poor in I
don't know Tehran or Senegal or cocaine
I don't know we poor anywhere frankly
he's pretty Grim to be poor in anywhere
in the world I've been pouring places
before but
I don't feel like our job is to train
people to bend themselves into a shape
where they can succeed Within These
systems I think our job is to train
people so that they learn to challenge
these systems to create fairer systems
that are not solely built upon the
Fulfillment of individual goals my
friend Adam Kerr is the great filmmaker
and genius says the genie is out of the
bottle now on individualism it's never
going back in you're never going to tell
people hey why don't you forget your own
identity you're just a member of a
community of a collective of a parish
you know that's not going to happen now
everyone live nothing is as real to you
or I as our own thoughts as our own
dreams as our own but that's that's the
way it is now but perhaps through this
we can attain some meaning and if I
refer back even to my own suggestions
serve the thing you are pursuing you
know if it's like you really want to go
out of a boy or a girl why are you
looking to serve them or do you think
they're going to somehow solve or
absolve you you've seen them as some
Salve or if you're after some dream why
is it because you don't feel like you're
good enough or you're worthy you know
one of my friends said like to me that
you're like someone who's been up to the
all-you-can-eat buffet table stuffed
your face full of everything and then
going to everyone else you don't need
this stuff
this cake won't work for you but
but I have had this experience so you
know you know anyone the same one that's
easy for you to say then yeah God damn
it they're right well it wasn't that
easy to get here let me tell you and
like so but what I would say is
this is I would say I would say this
that you are beautiful that you are
enough that you deserve to feel content
and happy but you have to be willing to
surrender everything you have to be
willing to surrender everything you have
to be willing to accept that what you
think you should get might not be right
where did it come from that idea where
did that idea that you know because if
you are meant to be a world-class
athlete if you get on and do you know I
mean do the Tony Robbins version of get
on and do the work don't let anything
stand in your way believe in it be
willing to suffer have the discipline
make the sacrifices then that's all sort
of cool but for the only reason you're
becoming a world-class athlete is
because your father told you you're not
good enough and that you're cheap and
you ain't no kind of a man or woman or
whatever then that you're gonna need to
deal with that otherwise you're gonna
end up strung up in a hotel room one way
or another you know because it doesn't
like you know like you and I both know
enough people like I've having
experienced the type of celebrity that I
experienced I've met people that as I'm
sure you have that are in at the Apex
the Zenith they have enjoyed it they've
been to Kubla Khan they've had it
they're in there and drowning in riches
and drowning indeed because it's not
real it's not real never lose sight of
the fact that we are in Limitless space
in every direction never lose sight of
the fact that in the sub particular
world the rules of physics as we
previously understood them are falling
apart never lose sight of the fact that
our senses are limited and we can only
see 0.63 of the electromagnetic range
that we are operating essentially in
darkness that the neural activity that
we experience that constitutes our
reality is only a tiny percentage of the
potential of our own brain let alone the
potential brain of God God wouldn't it
be a coincidence if we were issued with
all of the senses necessary to
experience total reality isn't it more
likely that we think of reality as just
being the circumference of our sensual
world so that there are Limitless
experiences as you unheard and men had
and many of them lay in the realm of
mystery engage with the mystery meditate
pursue these spiritual disciplines don't
rely entirely on the material path this
is not like you know neglect the body or
hate the body love the body we're in
this material world we are God made
flesh we are having this experience in
bodies but I don't think you can take
what this culture is offering you as a
solution and think that it will be a
solution you'll be disappointed the map
is not the territory the map is not the
territory when you get there it's not
like that it's not like that so you
start where you are start with you now
I'm number seven the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is take
control of your mind with brain trees
many years ago when Dr Norman Vincent
peel who was a colleague of mine while
he was still alive wrote a book called
The Power of Positive Thinking it's
still one of the most popular books on
personal success and personal
development ever written and his basic
message was is if you think in a
positive way you'll have positive
results and you'll be happy most of the
time
so how do you use the power of positive
thinking well they did a study at the
University of Pennsylvania it was funded
by some of the biggest companies in
America and over a 22-year period they
interviewed more than 350
000 people like you and I and ask them a
lot of questions about their lives and
their attitudes and so on and one of the
questions they ask them is what do you
think about most of the time then they
conducted a series of experiments is
they would have graduate students who
were working on their papers in
Psychology or sociology phoned these
people once a week at random during the
week and just say what are you thinking
about right now and they'd write it down
and the next week they'd call them on a
different day at a different time this
is all pre-arranged that they would be
expecting the call sometime and what are
you thinking about right now and then
write it down then they began to sort
these groups out in terms of deciles
which is ten percent the bottom 10
percent the next ten percent all the way
up to the top 10 percent and they
noticed that the people in the top 10
percent thought very differently from
people in the bottom 80 percent
what do top people think about most of
the time can you guess
the answer was so simple it was amazing
they think about what they want and how
to get it most of the time
they think about their goals and they
think about their priorities and they
think about their actions and activities
each day they think about the number of
people they need to call on and the
number of proposals they need to put
together and the number of things they
need to read and to study they're always
thinking about what they want and when
you think about what you want it makes
you happy it makes you positive makes
you feel in control of your whole life
and then they think about how to get it
so in my seminars I'll say that the most
important word for leadership and
success is the word how whenever you
have a goal the only question you ask is
how can I achieve this goal if I have a
problem how can I solve this problem if
you have an obstacle how can I over I'm
the obstacle top people think about what
they want and how to get it most of the
time and as a result they're thinking
about their goal and they're thinking
about the actions that they can take
every single minute of every day to move
faster toward achieving that goal Earl
Nightingale once said that happiness is
the progressive step-by-step
realization of a worthy ideal or goal
when you feel yourself moving step by
step each hour each day toward achieving
something that's important to you you
feel positive and happy most of the time
by the way do you know what unsuccessful
people think about most of the time they
think about what they don't want the
things that make them angry or sad
usually past events that they can't
change and they think about who's to
blame for all their problems
so whenever you see people talking and
complaining about things that they can't
change things in their life that are
their responsibility and then blaming
others for their problems you know
you're dealing with a negative unhappy
person with a very limited future and a
very unhappy present so the way you take
control of your mind like grabbing the
wheel of a vehicle is start to think
about what you want and how to get it
all day long and you automatically
become positive and start to feel in
complete control of your life
I was born in Belarus in the former
Soviet Union I came to the U.S when I
was three we lived a very humble
beginning as you can imagine the economy
wasn't super great we didn't speak
English we had a hundred bucks uh I
lived with seven family members in a
studio apartment in Queens so it was
super humble as you and you know
obviously my parents are very much my
heroes uh one because my mom is the
greatest parent of all time and two
because my dad worked his face off and
even though I slept under the same roof
literally every day of my life with my
dad in the first 14 years of my life I
literally never saw him because he left
at 7 A.M or 6 a.m and he came home at 10
p.m and he worked seven days a week how
many people here are immigrants or
children of immigrants raise your hands
awesome so this group that just raised
their hands they know that immigrants in
America have absolutely figured out one
of the core Secrets which is you know
work your face off and don't buy dumb
and so that's kind of what my family did
for seven or eight years you know we my
dad wasn't making that much money but a
funny thing happens when you buy nothing
but food at the lowest possible price
and uh save save save save save save and
very quickly only six years after Coming
To America with 100 bucks my dad was
able to buy a small liquor store in New
Jersey we moved to New Jersey that is
where my entrepreneurial career began uh
when I was six I had a five Lemonade
Stand franchise
I uh manipulated my friends into
standing behind the lemonade all day and
that is when I became obsessed with
attention and this is really interesting
as you can see up here I day trade
attention culture and build businesses
at six years old
I would spend my summer days literally
walking up and down the streets of New
Jersey
sitting down on the curb watching cars
drive by so that I could figure out
which tree or post was better for me to
put a sign that said lemonade a quarter
that is DNA that's like somebody singing
That's like somebody throwing a pitch
really like that is just pure DNA I
didn't read a Seth Godin book or go to
Harvard Business School to figure out
that attention was the number one asset
the one thing that combines every person
here from the cameraman back there who
are producing to the industry that is in
this room to me to Mickey to anybody
else that sneaked in the one thing that
fundamentally connects all of us is
before you tell me how great your
product and services you need my
attention so that I listen I am obsessed
with attention I am obsessed with this
device because it has the attention I am
unemotional if it's ruining the kids and
they don't know how to engage or that
you were sad that people go out to
dinner and don't talk to each other
technology does not care about your
feelings
and so I as a human may have some
opinions about Parenthood and and
society and privacy as a human
but as a businessman I am unemotional
and not romantic all I do is follow
where the attention is and I figure out
how to storytell in there to create the
action that I desire I was aware at that
moment how many times in my life
I've I've woken up like not sure
I think it started happening for me
uh years ago like like
probably around 12 or 13. I didn't know
what to do every day what's what's today
going to bring maybe it's after watching
so much TV and eating so much sugar you
know I think our diets definitely have a
lot to do with all that
but look I want to give you something
today about how to get out of the funk
the funky hunk dunk
when I by the time I was 25 this thing
went on from 12 to 25 at 25 years old I
was in so much depression every day I
was using drugs alcohol
I was self-medicating constantly
making bad decisions I lived in a 275
uh
uh I mean I just remember how much it
was it was 275 dollars a month and every
other month I couldn't make the bill the
payment I was late
today I live in this joint right here
live up on the 33rd floor of this place
and
a completely different life today than I
had then 25 I went to a treatment center
for 20 28 days for drug addiction I was
using drugs every day hated it
let me tell you something worse than
drugs it's how you feel about yourself I
hated myself every time I did a drug
every time I smoked weed every time
every time I did
any drug the moment I put the pill in my
mouth the weed to my mouth something in
my nose I hated myself
I never felt good
about using drugs
and so
by the time I was 25 I had been using
drugs for
10 years but my problems started before
that
my problems didn't start with the drugs
it started with my inability to manage
this
light grade chronic depression
this
for lack of better words this this idea
that I wasn't good enough this idea that
that
um
that um I didn't love myself you know
that that you know my my mom gave my mom
quit on me my mom told me hey don't come
around here anymore my twin brother
pretty much what's done with me
my sisters both knew that I was in
trouble and were like oh my God you know
we're gonna get a call on him today
the people I worked with the principal
at the high school I went to said I
couldn't couldn't win dog catcher
in my 11th and 12th grade told my mom
that
my student
my PE teacher said I would amount to
nothing I wrecked my car on my driver's
ed test I failed my driver's license
test I was fired from my first six jobs
wouldn't leave the sixth one dude I'm
telling you I was a loser
loser okay I'm telling you loser and I
didn't have to ask other people nobody
had to tell me I was a loser I knew I
was a loser
[Music]
so look if you've ever been there I know
there's people watching this right now
maybe you don't even know who I am
you're like who's this dude talking
about himself you know
I've come from that where I was bankrupt
spiritually financially physically I
weighed 134 pounds that's 40 pounds less
than I weigh today
I was broken every way possible I didn't
have any money I was in debt but worst
the worst thing the worst of the worst
of the worst
was how I felt about myself
I got out of that treatment center and
the counselor told me on the way out of
the treatment center if you read my last
book be obsessed or be average it was
the first book that I really shared
anything about my life
of all seven of my books that that one
gives you a kind of a look inside my
life more than anything
and um maybe what I'll do is in this
maybe what I'll do is I'll have my guys
give you give you a a chapter of that
book free
and um it's not what I came here to give
you I want to I do want to give you
something but maybe my guys could put a
couple of different links in here for
you
so
I got out of that treatment center and
the counselor said to me I think his
name was Philip I don't remember the guy
now I hated this guts then I still don't
think much of him he said to me God was
really confused
he was more confused than I was he said
now that I look back he said to me he
said to me he said hey if you leave here
if you leave here and you don't give up
you know because when you're there you
spill your guts you tell them everything
and I told them I wanted to be rich and
famous and and help people and write
books and you know be known all over the
world he says if you don't give all
those ideas I think he called it
grandiosity if you don't give up all
these grandiose ideas of changing the
world
uh being rich being famous
if you don't change all those ideas
dude you'll never ever ever make it
you'll never stay what do you call it
you'll never stay dry and sober if I've
got a friend in my life where a you know
a partner that I want to encourage to
come out of that place of Despair into a
better place how do I effectively do
that without overpowering them or
stifling them or making them feel
inadequate which is sometimes the
consequence of trying to change someone
you love well
example is good
but then I would say disabuse yourself
of the notion that you know what is best
for this person you don't not only do
you not no you actually don't want that
responsibility for two reasons
let's say they do what you say
and something good happens to them
well whose Victory is that
yours are theirs and if it's yours did
you just steal it
and then let's say they fail
following your advice well they pay the
price for that and you can skip away
merrily and say well I should have spoke
more carefully it's like you don't mess
about with people's Destiny you do not
know where they're headed now having
said that
you do what you're doing in this
interview in this podcast
you ask people questions
real questions you know like how are you
feeling
I'm not doing so good today well you
know what's up what's going on
and you can't think well I'm going to
ask questions to lead this person in a
particular direction because that's the
same game the same instrumental game you
have to see what it is that you want to
know I see this when people ask me
questions after my lectures you know now
now and then or during a q a now and
then people get up and they'll ask a
real question it's part of the ongoing
dialogue something struck them they
stand up there's something they really
want to know so honest question and that
goes real well but
not infrequently someone stands up with
a little prepared speech that's packaged
as a question so I get this from
Christian traditionalists fairly
frequently they get up and they ask me
about my religious convictions but
really what they want to do is Corner me
into admitting that I should accept
Jesus Christ as my savior and and join a
particular let's say uh
um denomination it's not a question
it's just a manipulation
and so your questions like your
statements your questions should be
honest and if you ask people questions
and you really listen they will untangle
themselves
and that's partly why people love to be
attended to you know like
if I meet people on the street you know
I ask them their name they're all
usually flustered when they come up to
me they don't really want to interrupt
me and then they're flustered and the
first thing I do is shake their hand and
ask them their name and I listen you
know not that good at remembering names
but I listen to it and and they know how
to say their name and so it kind of
settles them down and then it sort of
marks them out as a person against the
background eh and then if I pay
attention to them and listen they will
tell me something in like 10 seconds
that I need to know
because they are they have something to
say you know
and then if you listen people tell you
what they have to say and then you get
wise because you collect all that
and so you want to help someone
well first of all you would decide that
you're aiming towards help right
and and that you do that in the spirit
of ignorance this is what every good
clinician learns is I don't know where
you're headed I don't know what's wrong
with you this is a hard problem man it's
like what's your problem
I don't know what your problem is
so let's find that out first and then
let's find out
one thing you can ask people this is
actually useful in an argument with
someone you love they're they're upset
with you
what are your preconditions for
satisfaction
now I wouldn't state it like that it's
like
if I could give you what you wanted
right now in the context of this
argument and I wasn't doing it in a
manipulative way what is it that I would
have to say or do that would in
principle satisfy you
and that's a hard question you know and
the person might say well I think you
should apologize and about this and you
know and then I will say
what words should I use and they'll say
well if you loved me you'd know and I
would say no I'm stupid and ignorant and
I don't know what the right words are to
satisfy you so why don't you give me a
hand with that and I'll utter them
inelegantly and awkwardly in a good
faith demonstration of my commitment to
peace and that won't be so good because
maybe it would have been better if I
came up with it myself but maybe next
time I can do slightly better
and that works it it requires the person
who's after you to think through
the question even of whether there's
anything that could be said or done that
would satisfy them and if the answer to
that is no well probably the
relationship is over but certainly
the person that they're accusing has
been put in an absolutely impossible
position
but usually almost inevitably
if the person meditates on it for a bit
there is something that would satisfy
them that can be negotiated as long as
they're willing to give you the
opportunity to do it you know stupidly
and badly
so listening man
is Jimmy Carr I talked to Jimmy Carr two
weeks ago the Irish comedian yeah it was
real interesting
um he said comedy is the most dialogical
of
of the entertainment forms and I thought
well what do you mean by that because
you're just it's a monologue right now I
do monologues but I pay attention to the
audience right I'm always talking to
individual people in the audience and
watching their reactions and listening
to the audience as a whole so even
though it's a lecture let's say or a
talk
I'm watching the audience and responding
so we're in a kind of dance well Carr
pointed out that comedians before they
hit the road and this is virtually
invariably the case
they have their new routines so they're
they're Corpus of potentially funny
jokes and then they do 200 shows in
front of small audiences and
the audience either laughs or doesn't
and if you're listening you collect all
the jokes that people laugh out if you
do that 200 times you have nothing but
hilarious material but you listened and
then you can go out on the road and that
was very interesting to me because humor
is a mysterious
phenomenon experientially and
conceptually and it's sort of
precognitive and instinctual but it's
also extremely sophisticated then
there's an element of transcendence
about it right because you can laugh at
yourself and that's in some sense the
highest form of humor
and so it's so interesting that we can
criticize and Elevate ourselves at the
same time and that we find that
intensely pleasurable
and so a good comedian collects ways to
do that shares them with the audience
and he's listening and so if you want to
help someone
the best way to help someone is not to
give them advice
but to listen to them your challenges
don't only make you stronger they allow
you to serve better I think the default
answer for a lot of people is that your
challenges make you stronger your
challenges will you know to grow muscle
you have to break you have to break your
muscle first and all of these obstacles
that I put in your way allow you to have
a a better life they're making you
stronger they're making you more
powerful and that's all true yes and
the thing that helps me the most is just
tying it back to service because I think
you know humors are built to serve you
are built to serve when you can connect
the challenge that you're going through
as something that's then going to
inspire and help other people
at least for me it always gives me a lot
more strength and a lot more courage to
do the thing that I need to do as
opposed to just being about me getting
stronger I find a lot of times me
getting stronger is not enough it's not
enough of a reason compared to it's
going to help somebody else as well so
you know that's you hope this video
helps you as well so I think about
when I was doing my tour 2019 and I
broke my neck it was one of the most
challenging times in my life and that
it's already hard enough I'm already you
know on the road report of the year on
the road 90 straight days me Nina my
camera mandani and there were a lot of
challenges in making that whole tour
happen and new city every four days and
all of the stuff that goes into you know
it was my first ever tour and then I
broke my neck two-thirds of the way
through
so as if things weren't hard enough now
I break my neck I can't drive anymore uh
I'm in insane amounts of pain I have a
concussion uh and I'm still making
videos I I struggled with the decision
this is a real decision do I do I quit
the tour or not so I quit the tour do I
go home
there's still another month on the road
it's not just me it's also Nina who has
to do a lot more work now she's got to
drive this giant Suburban across the
country uh Danny the camera guy has to
do a lot more work you know it's a lot
of stress I'm basically out of
commission and all I could do was talk
it's great for speaking but it sucks for
everything else so what do we do
the thing that made me want to at least
try to keep going I didn't know that I
would go for another month but I thought
let's just do the next city let's just
do the next city let's go to Kansas City
Kansas City was the next stop
let's go to Kansas City and see what
happens
what got me through it was
thinking about somebody in the audience
thinking about one of you guys who is
struggling with something physically up
until that point I had dealt with a lot
of mental issues mental issues mindset
issues
things like believe in you not good
enough lack of self-worth you don't have
a message to share imposter syndrome all
of those things right even here we're
filming we're about to go through a car
wash uh we're we're next so we're
probably gonna get some crazy noise we
have to talk loud I used to
be so worried about that stuff that I
wouldn't I wouldn't feel like oh I can't
film going to a car wash you know the
noise whatever now I look at it as
opportunities like let's go like that's
not a good enough reason maybe the video
quality sucks I you know I hope not
um maybe you can't hear me loud enough I
hope not but but not letting those
things get in your way because that
stuff happens all the time you know like
that stuff happens all the time look
we're next you guys can see it says
Car Wash we're next depending on how
long that guy ahead of us takes you
might you might see it in this video I
dealt with a lot of those mindset issues
those lack of belief issues those
worthiness issues and I I battled them
and I've been through them and
yeah have a few lessons to share
and over the years of me trialing and
failing and you know 20 plus years of
doing this
my hope is to make the path a little bit
easier for you so that you don't have to
struggle as much as I did the path can
be a little bit sooner a little bit
faster a little bit less painful right
but I'd never been through anything
really physical you know I've broken my
toe
I remember breaking my toe
uh and then going for a run
and I was doing Instagram live at the
times like a light run fast Jog and I
like my toe was hurting so much and I
just kept powering through I didn't
later realize I broke my toe but that's
not really anything major right you know
if somebody's going through something
physical and major it's like you broke
your toe come on it's not a big deal and
so I never felt like I could
serve or push people who
had a physical limitation
I had a physical kind of injury because
I'd never gone through it and I don't
feel right pushing people on things that
I haven't experienced in some form
myself right
so here I am 2009 2019 now I break my
neck now I might have a concussion I'm
in more pain I've ever been in my life
concussion if you haven't been through
it is just devastating because it's not
just the physical pain of not being able
to move your body and you know neck and
potential having spinal surgery which is
crazy scary but also not being able to
think clearly first for me I I value
that a lot like I love thinking you know
I love problem solving and not being
able to think clearly and just be a
vegetable on the couch all day was was
devastating so getting through that and
then deciding I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
going
I'm gonna at least try for the next stop
in Kansas City why
because if I can get through this
yes it's a challenge that will teach me
and make me stronger and I have a lesson
that I can learn from it but
if I can get through this then hopefully
can serve as an inspiration for other
people who are going through something
physical as well but it's not just a
mindset issue but they have physical
limitations
you know the first couple the first
night in the hospital I was a you know a
train wreck then I came home and
uh to our Airbnb they let me out of the
hospital and I remember two specific
Moments One
trying to get into the car
so we're at the hospital I get
discharged I'm excited to go home fresh
air oh my gosh it's amazing and I have
this neck brace on I can't move I'm very
low flexibility and I'm now the
passenger I'm not allowed to drive
because I can't turn my head so Nina has
to Nina has to drive and I'm in the
parking lot of the hospital
and
I'm trying to get into the passenger
side I'm in the passenger seat right now
in my car I'm trying to get into the
passenger side of the car and I can't
and it hurts too much and I get to the
point where I have one foot in the car
and one foot out of the car
and it's a Suburban so there's this
giant step up to get in
and I remember being so
I was in so much pain
that I couldn't go forward into the car
I didn't have the strength and every
time I lift it off it it killed
everything in my body the whole like all
my back up into my neck everything was
in massive pain but I also couldn't get
back down
because that was hurting too much too so
I was in I was stuck in this limbo if I
can't go forward I can't go back
[Music]
Nina's trying to you know push me up to
get me in and then I remember just
crying
I'm in the parking lot of that oh we're
going to the car wash I'm in the parking
lot I'm gonna have to talk louder I'm in
the parking lot
of the hospital and I'm crying
out of frustration and I can't remember
the last time I was that frustrated that
I just broke down and cried and I I
didn't know what to do next everything
hurt I can't move forward I can't move
backwards I'm just overwhelmed by pain
and frustration and I'm crying in the
parking lot of the hospital
eventually Nina
just pushes me in
one hand on each butt cheek and like in
you go and I got it and it hurt but but
then I was in
and that was just
an overwhelming moment
and then I remember that night
here we go car wash
that night
uh it was I mean I can't sleep it's
terrible i've got you know neck brace on
I'm not used to sleeping with it I'm in
massive pain and it's it's three in the
morning
and I have to go to the bathroom
and so I'm sitting I I can get myself to
sit up they taught me in the hospital
how to push yourself from
um
lying down to
to sit in that blue look here comes look
at the foam look at that guys how to go
from lying down to sitting up without
hurting yourself too much like
minimizing the pain as much as possible
so they taught me how to do that
so three in the morning I have to go to
the bathroom I get up uh I push myself
into the seating position
I'm starting to feel dizzy I have a
concussion right I'm starting to feel
dizzy I can't see anything because it's
really dark and
I'm worried that if I stand up I might
fall over
how I got the concussion was I fainted I
fainted my head on the wall and then
cracked my my the back of my neck open
I'm worried that if I stand up I might
faint and I might fall over again
and I Nina's asleep next to me
look at this
were you sleeping on the floor Nina's
joining in no you're on the bed
she was afraid she's gonna wake me up I
mean bless Nina's Hearts I mean she had
no sleep during this whole time too
right so she's asleep it's three in the
morning and I and I
I don't want to wake her up
one because I feel bad for her because
she hasn't slept at all but also feel I
feel helpless I feel so helpless
that I mean all this pain and I can't
even go I can't even go to the bathroom
by myself like I need help to go to the
bathroom I felt so helpless and I said
it's it's not worth it for me to get up
and and potentially like if I fall
that's that's no bueno right I'm back to
the hospital probably if I fall so I
wake up Nina and I mean it may not seem
like a big deal but it it felt like a
big deal like I felt just helpless
and so I had I woke her up she helped me
go to the bathroom and you know I did my
business and went back to sleep but
those two moments in particular were the
most painful moments of that whole
experience
it's the best uh
and and the thing that got me through it
the thing that gave me the motivation
was that
hopefully somebody else who's going
through some kind of painful moment
right now
we'll be able to resonate with this and
be inspired by this whether it's
actually true or not it was a story that
I was telling myself I told myself
somebody's going to be inspired by this
and I still made videos and my next
round of videos I couldn't do the whole
thing so Nina did some of it I did some
of it
um and I'm sitting there I'm I'm now
overweight because I'm uh you know I
haven't been able to work out
um I've been eaten as clean as I was
normally I got a giant scab if you look
at some of those old videos I have this
huge scab on my forehead again
normally like oh my gosh I got this
giant scab on my you might be worried
about a little pimple look at this giant
scab coming down my forehead it looked
like Harry Potter the thing that gets me
through it is
other people
who have some kind of issue like they're
having a bad hair day or a pimple on
their face might be inspired by this to
go and take action what Nina has a
paintball whatever you want to show
everybody your pimple on your forehead
again whether it's true or not it was a
story that I was telling myself that
somebody else is going to be inspired by
this and it's going to allow them to go
and do their thing
um now fast forward
make the videos we release the videos a
lot of people were inspired by it a lot
of people did message me DM me email me
tell me in future interviews you know I
was I was telling myself I couldn't do
this because of X because I had a
headache
and here you are doing your videos with
a concussion
giant Scout on your face neck brace in
massive pain breaking your neck and I
told myself what I have no excuse I'm
gonna go do my thing because Evan did
his thing
but again whether it was true or not
the thing that got me to get through the
challenge in a way that I'm proud of
myself for
was the connection to service
that it's not just here to make me
stronger which it did made me incredibly
like I can't believe I did that that guy
is still in me that I could go and do
that again hopefully they'll break my
neck again but I could do that
It Made Me Stronger but even more
valuable
is me feeling like this is gonna mean
something to somebody else so whatever
challenge you're going through
understand that yes you know your
purpose Consulting your pain
this will make you a better person
but the thing that will help you get
through it at least from my experience
is connecting to somebody else
that there are tons of people out there
who are also struggling with the same
thing that you are struggling with right
now and when you get through it your
story will be an inspiration for them
your journey through it
will motivate them to have the courage
to show up for their lives as well and
when you can actually connect it to
service I think everything is better you
are built to serve
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to become the person you wanted to
be with Jordan Peterson check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there don't make a plan that is what
you should do make a plan that outlines
a future so that you can sit back and
say look if I had that future then all
the horrible things that are going to
happen to me are going to be worthwhile
that's what you want